posez le ministre de l'agriculture votre
réponse me déçoit car il ne s'agit pas
de la loi et galim mais il s'agit du
destin de l'agriculture est ce que je
pointe aujourd'hui c'est les
contradictions entre le discours et les
actes qui sont à mon avis au coeur du
malaise agricole vous dit soutenir la
transition écologique mais rien dans
votre budget pour accompagner
significativement une modification
profonde des modes de production
vous mettez en place une interdiction
des produits phyto mais rien pour
certaines filières dans l'impasse comme
le souligne votre propre majorité
vous avez fait adopter la loi et galim
censé sauver le revenu agricole
mais elle ne porte que sur 20% de ce
revenu et la théorie du ruissellement ne
fonctionne pas vous teniez vous dit
soutenir la compétitivité des
exploitations mais la même loi augmente
les charges et le différentiel est
devenue insoutenable et nous n'avons
jamais autant apporter vous pariez sur
la montée en gamme et vous soutenez les
accords commerciaux qui ouvre nos
marchés à des produits qui ne répondent
pas aux exigences de production c'est le
cas du ceta et c'est le cas la ddt de
l'accord sur les viandes bovine
américaine que le parlement européen
s'apprête à voter demain vous dit
préparer l'avenir mais vous laissez le
se préparer une pac avec une
renationalisation des budgets qui
favorisera une concurrence
intra-européenne mortifère
monsieur le ministre je crois
sincèrement qu'il nous faut une grande
loi
un grand projet de loi de programmation
pluriannuelle agricole dans lequel nous
parlerons de l'innovation de la
formation des investissements durables
et qui offrira un cap à nos agriculteurs
une ambition à notre pays un cap qui
donnera confiance à nos français qui
oublie trop souvent quel est notre
chance